We will look back and
say, what was most amazing
about this period is the
speed at which we developed
the vaccines and tested
then distributed them.
It took us four years
just to identify the virus
that caused AIDS in the eighties.
So just imagine COVID where
it's four years before we even
know what is causing the outbreak.
That's what would have
happened if this just shifted
20 years, 30 years earlier
in terms of when this outbreak happened.
The rapid advance in vaccine technology
which is bringing an end
to the COVID 19 pandemic
is best understood
in the context of a series
of innovations that more
than doubled life expectancy
over the last hundred years.
This is the single most
incredible thing that's happened
in a century, argues the science writer
Steven Johnson in his new book,
Extra Life, a Short History
of Living Longer, which is also
running as a series on PBS.
It's one of the greatest
achievements in human history.
The book explores how innovations
and epidemiological statistics,
artificial fertilizer,
toilets, and sanitation
systems, vaccines and more have
allowed billions of people
to flourish until old age.
Author and host Johnson
was a founder of the
pioneering website, Feed in the 1990s
and has authored a shelf full of books
about human progress,
including bestsellers, such
as The Ghost Map, which
recounted how doctors
and researchers ended the threat
of cholera in 19th century
London and Future Perfect,
which argues that the
modern network world is far
more resilient than previous iterations.
He talks with reason
about how humans manage to
massively increase their
lifespan in the 20th century
and whether we might do
even better in the 21st
Steven Johnson. Thanks
for talking to Reason.
Thanks for having me.
What's the elevator pitch of Extra Life:
a Short History of Living Longer.
It's right there on the subtitle, I guess
but the basic elevator pitch is,
the simple fact of the story
of life expectancy globally
over the past a hundred years,
if you rewound the clock to the kind
of end of the Spanish flu
in 1920, life expectancy
in the United States was about 41.
Globally, it was probably
somewhere around 35 and today
even in the middle of the worst pandemic
since then, global life
expectancy is just over 72.
So we have doubled the length
of the average human life in that period.
And this book begins with
the idea that that is
the single most important
thing that has happened
over the last hundred years.
If a newspaper came out once a century,
that would be the headline, I think.
Is it appreciated
or is it that, you know,
every, at any stage people are
like partway on that curve, you know?
So like they never really
get that full view.
Yeah, I think it's not appreciated.
I mean, if it was appreciated
I think we wouldn't be here talking
about the book because people
would have a sense of it.
And it's not appreciated
for two reasons, I think.
The first is that it's,
it's progress in the
in the shape that progress
normally takes, which is
that it's slow and incremental
and made out of, you know
hundreds of thousands of
small interventions and slow
incremental progress is
the least interesting thing
from a kind of a news
cycle perspective, right?
It just doesn't get covered.
And secondly, it's unlike other forms
of progress like your
smartphone or a skyscraper.
Those are kind of tangible
objects you can point
to and say, look, wow, I have
a super computer in my pocket.
That's amazing. That's progress.
With health, progress is measured
in this bizarre way in non events, right?
The progress is I didn't die
of smallpox when I was two
or that accident I was in.
I didn't, you know,
die in the car accident
because seatbelts were invented
and I had to wear them.
And so we don't tend to think
about events that didn't happen,
[Nick] Right.
for a reason, they didn't happen, right?
And so we get this skewed sense
of where the positive and
big changes are happening.
And it's also interesting, you point out
particularly in the 19th century
say in England and in the United States
and then globally in
different settings that
with the advent of industrialization,
which is really kind of
undergirding a lot of progress,
there were predictable,
or not predictable,
there were measurable
declines in health outcomes.
Where did that come from?
Because that also it, I mean,
industrialization and the move
into cities allows for
greater carrying capacity
but it actually brought
life down and, you know,
the 19th century England for a while.
You know, it's a funny thing, that period,
and particularly in England
but also in the United States
from about 1750 to 1850,
I keep coming back and
I've written about it a number of times.
And you know, sometimes
people are like, well
you're just such a Anglophile.
You know, you're just
obsessed with that period.
It's like, no, that period
is really interesting
because something is happening there
for the first time in the history
of the world, that is then
going to basically be exported
to the rest of the world.
And some of that is industrialization.
Some of that is urbanization,
but it's also a story of a
transformation in health.
And so two things are
happening in that period.
The first thing that's
interesting is that some subset
of the population in England
starts to live longer
in a steady sustained
way, starting around 1750.